world lockdown policies destroying the
future for america's children and it's
so bad even the new york times is
noticing kids are starting the new year
in crisis thanks to a year of pandemic
related social isolation
mental health is getting worse for teens
with a dramatic increase in emergency
department visits
suicide attempts are sharply up among
adolescent girls rising by 51
since 2019. gun violence against
children has increased in places like
chicago and there's an uptick in
disruptive behavior
all that is on top of the major loss in
learning from students not being in
classrooms president biden saying today
that he wants to keep schools open
all right all right then let's talk guys
about this crisis we knew during the
trump administration that kids were
suffering but why have we been so
willing to allow our kids to suffer uh
and disregard the damage to them
uh knowing that this was inevitable
i'll go to you greg well i mean
there's like there's we should come up
with a phrase called the five reality
lag
because we've been it's it's the time
between when we sound some alarm and
when the res and when the legacy media
finally goes oh yeah that is a problem
this is what's been going on with with
kovid since i don't know almost two
years and then if you look at the crime
at the crime issue which we've been
talking about and then there's this
reality lag but there's some obvious
truths here if there's a lack of
coherent structure in life that makes
life less appealing if you if you're if
you've got nothing to do life becomes
nothing and that's what i think you have
you're seeing a lot with kids who need
structure in their lives they don't just
need a goal they need a system because
sometimes you can't meet the goals
during during you know pandemic and then
you have their leading comorbidity you
know sixty percent of kids that are in
hospitals are clinically obese um due to
covid in a hospital because of covert
are also clinically obese that was a new
stat and it's like our country is run by
tony the tiger like all this sugar and
all these carbs we actually have to face
this it's we have to have a reckoning
with our diet because i think the the
pandemic has shined a light on a lot of
these stressed areas of our civilization
mental health fitness and diet and we're
finding out where our weak spots are
it's definitely our diet well there's no
question and dana you work out all the
time i mean you know what what we've got
are young people who are simply not
working out in addition to all of the
other harms i mean how do we make up for
not just the academic laws but the kids
who are suffering from you know not just
the suicide attempts but depression
anxiety isolation
panic all of the emotions that these
kids are now uh experiencing how to make
up for that well not only that but we
have robbed them of some serious
academic achievement and accomplishments
um and they know these kids know that
they're going to have to compete against
the world and that
their competitors like the chinese for
example are way ahead of them in terms
of some of the big
career choices that they'll have to make
in the future like stem classes science
technology and math
the other thing is free to learn this is
an education group just put out a poll
that said that 55 percent of parents
said that virtual learning has had a
negative impact on their child's
academic performance 60 percent said
that it had a negative impact on their
children's health so we all know that
this is happening what the government is
supposed to do and we're talking about
leadership in the a block instead of
following the five
several months later
you lead by doing risk analysis and
greg's talked about this a lot as well
so you do a cost benefit analysis
there's a whole office at in the office
of management and budget within the
executive office of the president that
basically that's all they do
is for example they want to raise
mileage standards for cars fine but you
have to weigh the risks of possibly
making the cars lighter which could lead
to more accidents more accidents leading
to more deaths and you do the
calculations and you figure it out and
as rational people we move forward we
now have tons of information this isn't
january of 2020 schools do not need to
be shut down right kids don't need to be
wearing masks that was in the atlantic
talk about the legacy media here you
have david lanhart of the new york times
who has finally well he should say
finally he's been very good on this
issue all along the great thing is that
once he says it
unlike when the five says it once he
says it then you'll see it repeated on
tomorrow morning's msnbc talk show well
jesse what about the fact that you know
are these kids going to be considered
like that lost two or three year group
uh in terms of you know going forward i
mean are people going to look back and
say you know what they can't do as well
academically or they're not doing as
well sports-wise socially because
they're a part of the pandemic
suppressed group of kids they'll be
stunted and they'll have a lot more
obstacles to overcome than a lot of
other students at the same age this
country talks such a big game about you
know judge put the children first it's
all about the kids how often do we hear
that it's all talk because the minute
that there was a little risk that little
johnny could come home from middle
school with something and sneeze on mom
and dad oh my god panic we're just going
to derail this kid's childhood for the
maybe the rest of his life i don't want
to downplay covid19 but other adults and
other generations judge went off to war
in the pacific in europe to save their
own children from communism
totalitarianism
but what did this generation
do
as soon as something came along that had
a 99
chance of survivability they they shut
everything down and all of a sudden the
media woke up to what we've been saying
for at least a year and a half but where
have they been
they know this hurts the children but
they waited and we know why they waited
because it was a political move to wait
now it's important to reopen now they
care about the kids they didn't care
about the kids when trump was president
well it's also an election year but
geraldo it brings me back to the first
question why were we so willing to
sacrifice the kids for the benefit of
some of the adults the teachers in
particular of course
because he was scared to death i think
that it's easy now to look back and say
oh we shouldn't have been as scared as
we were i remember a year ago i i just
am now tested positive
ten days ago
a year ago exactly a year ago my beloved
nephew bob reed died of this disease
he was 60 years old of two beautiful
children uh casey and tyler beautiful
wife michelle he died so the the the
deep concern we have is it was not uh
ill-founded uh you know now the omicron
is a whole different ballgame but wait
let me just finish this
the the gun violence i live in cleveland
they we have a terrible uh raid of
murder with kids and guns and every big
city you see what's happened across the
country cities across the country when
you take away the public school the only
structure these children have and you
have all these guns in in the in their
pockets uh what they do is they go out
and they act out and it's just horrible
and the final thing i want to say is
that i i'm very concerned about uh
exercise deprivation and you know the
the depression that comes with isolation
as the father of uh three girls uh you
know this these are real real issues
that we have to address and i i deplore
the fact that there's two sides there
should be one side on how to approach
that okay and greg's right about obesity
yeah he is and but you know in the end
you've got the uft you've got the
teachers who are still fighting to not
go back and that that doesn't in any way
take away from what happened a year or
two years ago i'm steve ducey i'm brian
kilmeade and i'm ainslie earhart and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis